his Twitter Instagram and YouTube
channels are only a part of the equation
there's three Netflix films and his
thinking of youth lifestyle streetwear
brand that he is rocking right now here
in person on the Rich Eisen show pride
of Toronto himself King batch good to
see you sir
thank you so do I call you what do you
prefer to be called it I just go by
batch batch you could call me Andrew
Andrew like but but it's Saudi again I
don't we've just met right it sounds to
me andrew is like something you're
called by a family member if you've
gotten into trouble exactly like Andrew
like that's the sort of yeah so I played
sports in high school and in sports I
usually call you by your last name okay
bachelor is it was too long it's
supposed to say so they would just call
me bad batch yes where did the King come
from King came from a high school
project I was doing I was a history
project I was the only one that dressed
up
I took it above and beyond and I I wore
the royalty of the cape and everything
and then my teachers like oh look at
King batch and I was like ooh that works
that's gonna make me a lot of money
that's gay that's called branding the
branding lightbulb went over your head
yeah what was the project that you know
was the King for I can't even remember I
just know it was ninth grade and I
probably failed it because I I was just
I just wanted to entertain my class was
a class clown cuz it sounds like again I
holdest son when it came time for like a
history project this year in fourth
grade he wanted to dress up as the
character oh and and I realized right
then and there it's because he thought
that was an easier way out then actually
study hey who the person the historical
figure is like you know you've got to do
more than just put on an outfit alright
you got to do the work that's what you
were doing yeah I was just putting on
that okay so if he comes home wow it
makes sense now that's about Stacey it's
all I gotta do is just like do it for a
king he comes home as King's an 18
million Instagram followers later boom
oh yeah fantastic yeah King back so
batch king batch Andrew that's the other
one yeah either one dealer's choice yeah
right here on the Rich Eisen show so you
are from Toronto yes how'd you make it
to Los Angeles
parents they just moved so my parents
came from Jamaica hmm went to school in
Canada York University okay
and then uh so they went from hot to
cold and the cold was too cold so I want
to go back to hot so they went to us
West Palm Beach okay and how did you get
your start how do I get my start yes sir
oh my gosh that's a long story I knew I
wanted to do acting since I was in the
third grade and your son was in the
fourth when that's right right okay so I
was in the third corner I should take
notes take notes because this is how it
happens how it happens
I knew I was watching uh I think it was
the mask or some movie with Jim Carrey
and or his aids mature I don't know
whichever one came first and I just
wanted to do what he was doing Jim
Carrey was your generation yeah I just
want to do it he was doing I didn't know
what it was called as I want to do that
and parents told me that that was acting
and ever since they that's called acting
young Andrew and then ever since then
that was my goals and I just didn't know
how I was gonna do it so I took acting
classes I got ripped off at some acting
schools what do you mean um well how can
I put them under the bus I mean look man
that's that's your that's your career
call but right you know as a host of a
show that trades off sort of stuff like
this please
there's a bus throw him under John
Robert Powers expose boom okay so I went
to this school West Palm Beach and they
have campuses all over and they're close
by the way by the way yeah that's that's
your West Palm Beach that's the start
happened in Florida okay okay so we're
paying like thousands of dollars for
these acting classes in West Palm what
could possibly go wrong from here I
don't understand okay so anyway oh yeah
everybody trains Shia LaBeouf trains
here and this gets better cuz that's
where he learned how to do his this is
the biggest
all right it gets it gets it gets better
okay yeah so they fly they uh they don't
fly us out to New York they say hey so
we got a thing in New York we're gonna
have 50 agents come out and you guys
perform your monologue and you may get
discovered but you gotta buy your own
plane ticket and all that so we buy our
plane tickets we go to New York we all
sign up it's like $1,500 for this for
this thing and it's like that's serious
coin 400 400 people there right like
kids like it like from each like
different states like they have jon
brower powers all over the United States
uh-huh so um we're all day and we're all
nervous and we're all like doing our
monologues and then we do the the
callbacks and I got 20 agents I wanted
to sign me and I got a scholarship to
some to some acting school mm-hmm
came to find out all those ages were
fake
they were fake agent fake agents yes
Robert Powers and nothing happened and
nothing happened so then how'd you get
your big break like what was I just
going so that was just a bump in the
road was that like vines or every set oh
yes so that was like when I was 15 and
we would go around and we perform at
different malls so I'm still like doing
the craft I'm still like learning on the
way Florida State University track and
field there and at Florida State I
started making YouTube videos that's
when it started then I started doing
stand-up comedy then I moved out to LA
more YouTube videos and then vine came
out and then vine was my like big break
that was your big bro yes seven seconds
of pop that's about it yeah yep six
point five want to be exact
spoken like a true connoisseur of the
medium yeah it is amazing how 6.5
seconds if you do it right and you
continue to do it and it catches fire I
mean you have over two million followers
on Twitter 18 million on Instagram right
now that is a serious platform yeah that
you have yeah batch there's no question
about that
yeah and Florida State you ran track for
Florida State
we won nationals three times in a row
what you when I was there what was your
energy the high jump the high jump yeah
I jumped seven feet two and a half
inches could you do that right now
impossible no way
no way what do you mean I'm old but I
understand how old
I'm 31 when was the last time you had
jumped 2010 they don't have that
equipment out anymore it's about to say
the tides up still an event still it's
gotta be I guess it's one of those
things where you need you need you need
the run-up right you need the setup you
need the landing area right and then you
need what else you need you just need
the hops well I need the hops July 27th
I'm doing a track meet yeah but it's
like it's a charity track meet logan
paul another youtuber sure he eats he
said he's a fastest youtuber and he
wants to bet $100,000 on it mmm
so I'm about to win $100,000 on July 25
you know I hope you take him for all
he's worth to be honest maybe if I could
see stuff a little good but I just found
your high jump video you found it
there's a high jump video impressive I'm
good right yeah seven two and a half
that's Talent you know I earn it the the
the logo of the show is me running the
40-yard dash in my suit every year at
the NFL's got a good time is that the on
the on the my I've seen the video on the
mug yeah what time is that on the mug I
would say this is my fastest when you
say 594 certainly since the the image is
Photoshop to my awkwardly angled right
leg put underneath my body and a much
more respectable polemically good thank
you batch I appreciate you can be like a
Tom Cruise movie
I'm almost I'm three years younger than
Tom Cruise right just don't fight Tom
Cruise like favor just save it to be
that's not gonna happen is it is that
really happening
is that really happening Cruz versus
Weaver Dana White said he had an actual
phone call about it hmm that's crazy
what's the one thinking batch here in
the Rich Eisen sure what's the one thing
that you had an idea for to put on
YouTube or put on something you thought
that's that's too much for me to even do
oh I can't miss a here you can't even
say that's that much is that really this
is what I realized about comedy most
comedy offends someone right if it's
yeah that's what comedy is but you have
to know what what your limitations are
okay
so when I'm doing comedy I try to I've
learned this in through
through mistakes that I've made that you
can't do what what what's going up in
here you have to do what everyone finds
acceptable because if you do too much
and you really say what you want to say
you're gonna offend the wrong people and
those people are gonna come back and and
it lives on the internet ever and then
your hashtagged on Twitter and then
you're cancelled and then so you can't
even say into a microphone what what are
you having even cuz they'll they'll take
the clip and they'll run it okay
well then what's the one that you're
most proud of them um the most that
you're like I'm glad I did that I said
anything you've done YouTube yeah there
was a III did a parody of Denzel
Washington on the movie flight and the
movie equalizer and the movie fences
okay and those are my favorite videos
that Denzel Washington so you do a good
Denzil it's okay cuz I mean that that's
that's one of those where if you don't
nail if you don't stick the landing
tonight I guess the the track-and-field
phrase yeah you want to try it all right
what the Denzel right now okay all right
now you want me to you want me to
channel Denzel Washington can you tell
me how Denzel will handle like what's
have Denzel tell me what's going on in
Toronto your native Toronto with Kawhi
Leonard coming to Los Angeles can you do
that right alright so this is what Kawhi
is doing my man he he he won a
championship already hmm okay all right
he wants you he won and he won another
one okay all right now he wants to win a
third I don't I don't I don't know what
he's trying to do I don't know what's
going on in his head
huh but he's trying to break a record
but the record can't be broken rim of
the world is just one of three Netflix
projects that did that coffee and Kareem
yes with taraji P Henson write an EDL Ed
Helms that's neat
yeah that was fun okay holiday tis with
Emma Roberts and Christian Chenoweth
yeah there's some great coat cohorts
that you've got going I'm working I'm
not a miner anymore Emery I'm a real
you are I mean the clip we just showed
us longer than 6.5 sighs I made it then
we just showed that of Rimmer the world
as well and what what do you what do you
enjoy about doing what you're growing
into right now I just love the creative
freedom that most of these directors
give me and I get to play characters
like like Jim Carrey like I haven't
gotten to a level where I can play like
you know those crazy characters you turn
them in you know everything's it's a
building you know what I mean so I'm I'm
on those I'm on that ladder I'm climbing
to the top but yeah I just love playing
different characters and then you're
wearing right now you're thinking of
youth lifestyle streetwear brand what is
that's what toi stands for yeah thinking
of you where'd you come up with this
idea because if you think about it the
youth mm-hmm that's the future so we
want to shape and shift the youth mm-hmm
so they can make a better future I'm not
super you're putting on your clothes
room yeah I love that idea and then on
the end of this month on IFC executive
produced by John Legend Sherman's
showcase a static sketch series now
that's that I would think is totally up
your alley it is series play when you
talk about Jim Carrey I mean obviously
you know that's where he got his big
huge start before all the film's yet on
in living color yeah and now sketches
here's the thing the sketches now are re
are changing now because people are
doing them so much so now it's becoming
like real shows mm-hmm so that's what's
good about this show sermons okay well
of course and then you know I need to
tell you that you know sketches two and
a half minutes three minutes long that
that's the stuff that I that I follow a
lot of sketch shows on social media just
seeing just seeing in the poem man yeah
my feet are so my favorite people
of course Chappelle show and key and
Peele key and Peele let me tell you
something we we had kion here right and
we're we're we're constantly knocking on
Jordan peels door the video of them
doing the mock Monday Night Football
oh yes liars announcing themselves and
what school they are from he's one of
the
videos I have ever ever seen it's
hilarious that is one of my favorite and
and and key when he came on the show
said that that came out of Jordan peels
mind overnight and he came in the neck
they came up with this idea to do that
and he said that Jordan Peele came in
the next day with about three different
sheets of different way it's amazing
it's crazy I did I did one episode of
their show and we actually sold a show
to Fox like maybe four or five years ago
right a long time ago but yeah they're
great guys well good luck to you
batch come back the first of many times
you come here and we'll just you know
just chop it up like we just did I mean
so you got you got three again different
platforms Twitter Instagram than your
YouTube channel bachelor's pad TV you've
got rim of the world coffee and Kareem
holiday on Netflix
Sherman's showcase coming up on IFC you
got your new comedy single HTH my gosh
and then your lifestyle brand yeah I
think I hit it all wrong you hate it all
I just pulled a hamstring doing that I
need to hydrate but thanks for coming on
thanks for having you got it act came
back on Instagram and Twitter Andrew
bachelor aka king batch aka batch the
king right here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app